elles sont avec nous ce soir c'est moi
alors je vous le dis c'est la première
fois c'est très rare c'est moi c'est
moi-même elles ont rien demandé c'est
moi qui ai demandé
aux équipes de les inviter j'ai les
cheveux je les adore je suis fan les
frangines
merci d'être là qu'est-ce que je suis je
suis content de vous voir on va écouter
votre nouveau single c'est pas ta faute
c'est pas ta faute c'est ce qu'on a dit
à Gilles quand il a voulu
très content de vous voir
vous avez vu que vous avez une troisième
frangine Béatrice qui est habillé
on est très content de vous recevoir on
adore ce que vous faites franchement
Mathieu tu adores ah bah j'ai vu tout à
l'heure là vous parler
de maquillage non non c'est vrai j'ai vu
l'émission de vendredi ou de vous parler
d'elle avec une petite jeune fille qui
était là et c'est vrai que j'adore aussi
mais j'ai demandé pourquoi vous vous
appelez les frangines c'est une question
qu'on nous pose jamais
[Applaudissements]
mettre
un piège voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour entendre ses conneries
franchement c'est dingue non mais
franchement je suis très heureux que
vous soyez franchement vous savez pas
comment je vous kiffe on peut pas
remettre des chansons des frangines à
deux secondes là mettez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de remettre cela j'aimerais qu'on
mette le moment ouais
[Musique]
c'est hyper touchant
[Rires]
on va voir déjà le clip c'est pas ta
faute regardez c'est co-écris avec celui
que j'adore aussi Vianney
qui nous regarde souvent qui m'envoie
des petits messages je fais un gros
bisou c'est parti
je t'écoute j'ai tous les organes nul
doute ni Remo si je comprends bien c'est
pas ta faute
[Musique]
c'est comme les autres et mon cœur c'est
pas toi qui la cassé c'est pas ta faute
je suis comme les autres vacances les
autres les paraissaient
[Musique]
pas laisser
elles seront au Zénith de Paris
le 1er avril 2023 réserver dès
maintenant c'est la folie et en tournée
dans toute la France les frangines elles
sont là après un premier album certifié
platine
et le deuxième album
note note
on est très heureux de vous avoir vous
n'êtes pas du tout ça non du coup pour
la pour la réponse
donc voilà c'était naturel de donner ce
titre les Français
[Applaudissements]
ils ont fait un eras plus dans le
Languedoc
non mais c'est vrai non mais qui déjà
parti comme ça non vous avez pas fait
d'études
en Irlande absolument je te crois pas
bien sûr toi tu es en Irlande ça a été
le seul le pire c'est genre de ma vie
non pas du tout mais
les gens étaient les gens étaient très
bizarre très bizarre
et et j'ai trouvé que la dame avait je
trouvais que la dame avait un regard
bizarre et une Adam bah la dame qui me
recevait qui était la maman moi j'étais
petit j'avais presque 14 ans et en fait
un jour je vais pour me laver les dents
dans la dans la salle de bain et là et
là je vois sur le bus sur le bidet je
vois son œil dans le binaire en fait
elle avait un œil qu'elle a enlevé
ça
arrive
lui il en est bien c'est corones on
rentre à la maison
[Applaudissements]